when you hear the word gravity you
probably just think of things falling
like an apple from a tree
but did you know it's also the reason
why your lamp is staying on the floor
that's because gravity is so much more
than things falling down
gravitational forces are these invisible
forces that pull objects together
so gravitational force is actually
attracting the lamp to the floor
and these forces exist between all
objects with mass
so let's write these key points out
about gravitational forces which i'm
going to use gf to represent
we said they are attractive forces
and that they exist between
all objects with mass
objects with
mass
to explain this we first need to
remember a couple of things
mass is how much matter
objects have
and matter is the stuff an object is
made of
any object with mass generates a
gravitational pull so there is a
gravitational force of attraction
between every object
the amount of gravitational force
between two objects will depend on two
things
the masses of the two objects
and the distance between them
the mass of each object is proportional
to the gravitational force this means
that the more mass an object has
the stronger its gravitational force
and now we can understand why gravity
makes things fall the earth is massive
literally
it's almost 6 septillion
kilograms
that's a 6 with 24 zeros after it
so it generates a huge attractive force
for comparison my lamp is only one
kilogram which is why if i jump i fall
towards the earth and not towards my
lamp
but we said the mass of the object is
just one factor affecting the strength
of its gravitational force
the other is the distance between
objects
the more distance between the objects
the weaker the gravitational pull
between them
for small objects without much mass it
doesn't take much distance for their
gravitational forces between each other
to be so weak that we don't notice them
for something like the earth you have to
go really far away to not be affected by
its gravitational force of attraction
i mean look at the moon it's almost 240
000 miles away that's almost 400 000
kilometers away and it still feels
effects from earth's gravity
that's why it's orbiting us
but since the moon is also a pretty
massive object we do experience the
effects of its gravitational pull on the
earth
this is why we have tides
the moon's gravitational force will pull
on earth's water which results in us
having high and low tides
now you might be wondering if gravity
can affect the moon or cause tides how
can we even move around why aren't we
just face planted on the ground because
earth's gravity is pulling us towards it
it turns out that actually gravity is a
pretty weak force we only even notice
its effects when an object is massive
like planets or stars
and the gravitational force on you is
way weaker than most forces you exert
every day in fact every time you pick up
a glass of water you're overpowering the
entire mass of earth how cool is that